what's up guys Hunter Hayes here you're
checking out certified country with my
friend Sophie she lacy hello hello
welcome to certified country I'm Sophie
shal AC and today is all about my buddy
Hunter Hayes
[Applause]
oh boy
[Music]
I've known hunter for a few years now
and I'm super excited and proud of what
he's got in the works because not only
is his new music so good he's continuing
to shake up the release game he's
embraced streaming and he's truly
putting the fans first which to be
perfectly frank is something that every
artist says but hunter is really putting
his money where his mouth is
we talked all about exactly what that
means at the historic Ryman Auditorium
in Nashville Mother Church herself just
last month and I had a little surprise
for him to take a look we have talked
about this before but I always want to
thank you for your song I want crazy
because I'm so special to my husband and
I when we were dating and we were
long-distance that song meant so much
just looking myself alongside got a few
color in your eyes but I haven't told
you this yet but at our wedding we use
that as a recessional song after they
said I pronounce you man and wife are
you serious back down the aisle your
song played I love the job so thank you
for that I love that
[Music]
you may cost you
[Music]
easy crazy that makes me so hot yeah me
too I'm honored I know you have a
special lady in your life do you have
songs that mean those kind of things to
you both rescue is that for me
I'm definitely talking about her and I
mean there's so many lines you can you
can read and feel it amen 100%
[Music]
my
[Applause]
the stuff that we've gone through
together and the stuff that she's seen
me go through and the strengths that
she's given me and have our songs and
there'll be more coming out soon to that
you'll hear more about
[Music]
now let's talk about your new music okay
tell me about the process and what
you're working on right now okay so
thank you back for a minute let's go
back in time to September September we
released three new songs so we released
a song called Amen
we released yesterday song and
Youngblood and that to me was like this
is new this is the new chapter this is
the starting over this is kind of the
fresh start the 21 project we released
like a song at a time and really found a
lot of fans responded well to that they
spoke so strongly about the way they
want us to release music and and how we
should release music that it completely
opened the doors they made such a
statement to the industry saying you
know the times are changing and we have
so many other avenues to release music
to them through country is rooted in
tradition I would say and the
traditional format was always released
single maybe two album and you have been
totally bucking that as I tribute to the
fans I would say really being successful
at it
yeah so is it scary to go that new route
and what is the next trend for you it's
absolutely frightening yeah right
because it's new and you've never done
it I think it's scarier even to the
business side of things who are used to
the not so much as traditions as much as
just like what we're used to there's so
many other ways to connect with the fans
there's so many of the places for us to
put music into and to create music for
because we write a hundred songs for a
ten song record yeah
to know that we're not limited you know
exclusively to a ten song record but we
can do a lot more is really excited is
there the opportunity to throw all 100
out there that's a good question
that's I've actually asked that question
because I'm wondering I mean can we can
we figure this out you know I don't know
I don't have any of the answers to that
I think a lot of songs that I really
care about that would have been left in
the dust in the past yeah now have a
chance to breathe and live but be real
with me though are there some where
you're like no this belongs in the
garbage absolutely how do you decide you
just know you just know there's tons of
stuff that I'm just like forget about
nobody's ever going to hear that I have
my way yeah totally
goodbye yeah exactly hunters knew a
single rescue did make the cut it is out
now he's also teamed up with Zappos to
create a limited-edition line of shoes
called the rescue collection that will
benefit various music and pet related
charities which are to causes very
to my heart as well before we wrap
things up here I'm going to leave you
once again with my songs of the week
beginning with another fielded love song
a long and happy life by Delta reg
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we
following up one of my favorite jams of
the moment hardik on the dance floor by
john party
[Music]
and last but certainly not least Walker
Hayes no relation to Hunter with you
broke up with me you can talk with just
uh Sam what we'd all be rainin on my
party proper ray Oh fun fact that song
is not about a romantic relationship
it's actually about Walker's early
experience with rejection in the music
industry so you're going to want to go
ahead and hit repeat on that one because
that tidbit made me love the song even
more all right tell me your favorites by
commenting below and on Instagram I am
at Sophie's Lacey and don't forget to
Like and subscribe to Entertainment
Tonight
we'll be back again next Friday right
here on YouTube see you then
[Music]